you cannot know ahead of time exactly
what's gonna come out because if you
knew it wouldn't be research you don't
expect your payoffs to be measured in
months or even necessarily a couple of
years but it could be that the things
you're doing now pay off ten years later
and so Microsoft has decided that MSR is
in it for the long term and that changes
the type of research that you can do
right you can afford to make big bets
you're listening to the Microsoft
Research podcast a show that brings you
closer to the cutting edge of technology
research and the scientists behind it
I'm your host Gretchen using uh teaching
computers to read think and communicate
like humans is a daunting task but it's
one that dr. Jeff Gordon embraces with
enthusiasm and optimism moving from an
academic role at Carnegie Mellon
University to a new role as research
director of the Microsoft research lab
in Montreal dr. Gordon embodies the
current trend toward the partnership
between academia and industry as we
enter what many believe will be a new
era of progress in machine learning and
artificial intelligence today dr. Gordon
gives us a brief history of AI including
his assessment of why we might see a
break in the weather pattern of AI
winters talks about how collaboration is
essential to innovation in machine
learning shares his vision of the
mindset it takes to tackle the biggest
questions in AI and reveals his lifelong
quest to make computers less well less
computer life that and much more on this
episode of the Microsoft Research
podcast
[Music]
Jeff Gordon thanks for coming all the
way from Montreal to join us in the
studio today welcome to the podcast
thank you I'm glad to be here Montreal
has become a global center for AI
research and you've just moved from
Carnegie Mellon University to take on
the role of research director at the
Microsoft Research Montreal lab we'll
get to your work a bit later but right
now what's the deal with Montreal how is
it come to be one of the most exciting
places in AI research yeah it's pretty
amazing how Montreal has been sort of
taking over AI it started with the deep
learning revolution because a lot of the
people who were sort of early in on that
revolution were from Canada and from
this area yoshua bengio is a key figure
that everybody's sort of credits with
bringing so much AI to Montreal but at
this point it's taken on a life of its
own it's growing by leaps and bounds
yeah it's like you get one person there
who starts something and then it becomes
a magnet and there's a lot of credit to
the Canadian government as well they've
been trying really hard to make it an
attractive place they sort of understand
what research needs to prosper and
they've actively been trying to recruit
talent to the area so that it's more
than just industry right I mean it's
government it's the universities in the
area and industry all together making
every great place to do AI work let's
talk about you for just a quick second
here you told me what you say to people
when they ask you what you do for a
living
and give our listeners your elevator
pitch and then maybe unpack it a bit
more assuming we're interested enough to
ask the next question sure sure so what
I always say is you know how computers
are annoying and inflexible my job is to
try and change that AI is sort of all
about making computers less computer
like that's a very concise statement
packed with technical work today ya know
it turns out it turns out it's easier
said than done I like the simplicity of
it but um so I've already interviewed a
couple of I'll call them rock stars from
your band there
Ben Sian who's doing great stuff with
reinforcement learning and Adam trishla
who's doing machine comprehension I have
to say it's just fascinating what's
going on at the Montreal lab what drew
you there to be the frontman so to speak
so the Montreal area is one thing the
other thing is just respect for the work
that MSR has been doing Microsoft
research has developed sort of a
reputation for putting together the best
of academic and industrial style
research the sort of focus on the long
term big goals which I like from
academia and very few industrial
research labs really try for that and
then there's the ability to build a
focus team that's doing something big in
academia your team is you and however
many grad students you can recruit and
how much the grant will pay for so the
goal of the MSR Montreal lab is very
specific to teach machines to read sync
and communicate like humans mm-hmm
that's right and this kind of learning
has traditionally been the domain of
humans so yes why do you think this is
possible for a machine and where are we
on the path to achieving that right well
we're a long way from fully achieving it
but we're making lots of progress on the
way and the first wave of AI was what I
would call very logical so somebody
would put in a bunch of logical facts
and syllogisms and that sort of thing
and they would hope that you would wind
up with enough facts and enough rule so
that you would know how to think and
that didn't work out so well you were
able to do with that some pretty
impressive things but you were
completely unable to handle uncertainty
and humans are great at handling
uncertainty they may not like it a lot
all of the time but you're handling
uncertainty every second of every day
even right now we're handling
uncertainty yeah I don't know what
you're gonna say no no me either
isn't that cool though cuz I can
actually formulate what we're gonna say
next right right we make it up as we go
along that's what humans are good at how
do I know what I think until I see what
I say yeah hmm that's profound so keep
going
ai right and so the next sort of big
thing was well okay let's try and handle
uncertainty in there with these things
like pattern recognition and that was
sort of very short-term thinking right
it was you see the picture and you tell
it to face and then you're done right
and then the next picture comes up so
that's the sort of thing that's in your
cell phone camera now people made
progress on it starting many years ago
but now it's in everybody's cell phone
camera right draws a box around
everybody's face and focuses there and
it's still to some degree shocks me oh
it amazes me you look at kids and what
they learn you know I spend all of my
working hours trying to get computers to
learn things and then I go home and I
talk with my kids and I'm like man I
have a long way to go so where are we
now so I think now we're sort of getting
to the point where we're trying to
combine these two capabilities where
there's this sort of reasoning ahead
capability with this capability to
recognize and react and I think you know
language is a good example where you
combine the structure language is
ambiguous we never realize it right but
like I saw the men with a telescope were
you using a telescope to see the man or
was the man carrying and tell us that's
a source of our uncertainty but there's
a lot of structure to it right
you know what the phrases are within a
sentence you know what the relationships
are among the words well okay so we're
making progress we're a long way off
mm-hmm and yet this is a big commitment
of the lab in Montreal is - yeah it's a
big bet see the next thing yeah I mean
the nice thing is that this is the sort
of bet that you always win research is
you go in thinking you're gonna
accomplish one thing and you know a
large fraction of the time you don't
accomplish that but you accomplish
something cool anyway there's a famous
quote researches what I'm doing when I
don't know what I'm doing I love that
yeah it kind of feels like a metaphor
for life in some ways yeah I must be
doing research a lot of the time we all
are right it's like trial and error so
there are a lot of approaches to machine
learning that researchers are exploring
and MSR Montreal is really known for its
work in at least two of them deep
in reinforcement learning that's right
so give us an overview of the technical
side of these approaches and how they've
advanced the science of a machine
learning mhm so people have known how a
little bit about how brains work for a
long time right there's these simple
processing elements but there's you know
a billion of them and they work together
to achieve something that no single one
of them could do on their own and so
people have tried to make computers
learn that way so people when they first
saw that you could do this they were
like oh my god this is gonna be great
this is gonna solve a AI and they sort
of overhyped it and maybe ten years
later the government stopped sending
money into grants for that the companies
stopped investing in it and it was what
was called the AI winter and then people
started realizing that was actually a
pretty cool idea and people had sort of
the next wave of neural networks maybe
20 30 years later where they were able
to train simple neural networks to do
interesting things and again everybody's
like oh my god this is gonna change the
world and overhyped it and after a
little while you we had the second AI
winter now I think at the risk of making
a prediction we're back where people are
really excited about neural networks and
I think the change this time is that
people have figured out how to work with
much larger and more complicated
networks and have shown success in
training these ones and they can do sort
of qualitatively more than their earlier
cousins and now a student of history
would say well we're headed for another
AI winter but I'm a little skeptical of
that because now there are so many real
shipping products that actually have
this technology baked into them right
like it's not gonna go away things might
change in the future but I don't think
it's gonna play out the same way that it
did last time
right there are tools in place mm-hmm
compute power algorithms
yes massive data sets yeah that weren't
there for the neural networks 50 years
ago right absolutely I mean the neural
networks 50 years ago I've seen a photo
of them it's like a bank of hardware
bigger than this room and it was there
to train a neural network with one unit
and it had potentiometers very
resistors and motors and it would train
by physically turning the knobs with the
motors like the Alan Turing Enigma
machine mm-hmm right the knobs and dials
and Wow yeah going off-script a little
bit I just had a thing on my Twitter
feed said there's 11 seasons in
Washington State winter fool spring
second winter spring of Deception a
third winter my disease an actual spring
summer false false second summer actual
fall a lot of winters in there though
yeah and you know you never know right
you never know if it's a yes like a I
the one thing we were talking about
uncertainty right the one thing that you
know is that you don't know what's gonna
happen
right and yet you're working on the
discovery and that's the exciting thing
about being a researcher yet is talk a
little bit more about reinforcement
learning because that's a big bet over
the lab harm gave me a good explanation
a while ago but I'd like to hear just
for the audience now they haven't heard
harms podcast right and they should go
back and rest because he's really a rock
star I love him so reinforcement
learning it's the problem where you have
your AI the thing that you're trying to
train and it interacts with its
environment so it's usually called the
agent in the world the agent is the AI
and the world is the thing it's
interacting with and what happens you
look at the world so you get
observations of the world those keep
coming in over time and when each
observation comes in you have to choose
actions to affect the world and this
sort of cycle of action and observation
with some thought in between hopefully
is the definition of the reinforcement
learning problem and then there's one
more component which is that based on
your entire history of actions and
observations the world can from time to
time give you a reward or a penalty
right so you know you eat a dot and miss
pac-man right it gives you ten points or
something like that or you know you run
into the ghost and you lose a life and
that's bad and so your goal and
enforcement learning is to have the AI
realize which actions tend to lead to
reward and which ones tend to lead to
penalty and it's difficult because you
never know right like you didn't you
might have done something several
seconds ago that leads to you being
trapped by the ghost and it's not what
you did like right before you got eaten
by the ghost right it's the thing that
you did that got you trapped and you
have to go back and figure out what that
was
let's talk about language because that's
the epicenter of your work when I was
talking to Adam about how a machine can
comprehend and work with in the domain
of language he was saying you know
you'll give it data sets of a statement
like machine learning is hard or machine
learning is difficult it's like and then
the computer is only recognizing what
it's been fed why are we kind of poised
to see big advances in the domain of
language as far as computers are
concerned right there's fairly amazing
language comprehension baked into
products that we use every day right
like my phone will do it and you know I
think part of the reason that it's been
more recent that that's made its way
into products is actually not a flaw in
the technology but it's taken this long
for that much computing power to become
cheap enough to put into consumer
products it keeps getting cheaper and
you know we passed a threshold at some
point where now companies can ship you
know a hundred dollar consumer
electronics product that can recognize
your voice one of the other things that
has been great for language research is
the fact that people put up so much
language on the web and so you can get a
billion word corpus of language you have
to be a major company in order to have
the resources to process that we are
working for one well yeah as it turns
out but you know you can go and you can
say okay you know hard is used in a lot
of the same contexts as difficult and so
those are similar words and actually
easy as a similar word too hard because
easy and hard are used in a lot of the
same context whereas you know avocado
very few sentences could you substitute
avocado for the word difficult right and
so you can also use hard for like on
rock right absolutely and so you're
effectively I mean you can cluster the
different meanings right these are
called vector space embeddings of words
so you can come and make a description
of a word in terms of a list of numbers
such that the list of numbers is similar
for words that occur in similar contexts
and when you do that words that have
sort of similar vectors similar lists of
numbers wind up being often quite close
in meaning right so I imagine the
algorithms behind all this are pretty
complicated oh but that's the fun part
for you so let's talk about learning for
inference that's an interesting thread
of your research what goes into
developing a machines skill set for long
term thinking well so the key problem
that you have to solve is that when you
learn some concept in isolation you wind
up not necessarily being able to use
that concept and so we're essentially
trying to design algorithms that make
that distinction
that give a computer experience at using
a learned concept and train it so that
it's better at doing that rather than
just trying to learn the concepts in
isolation you can start by learning them
in isolation but then you have to try
putting them together actually using
them to make a chain of reasoning okay
so what's the math look like behind that
I mean there's there's a lot of it
the simplest bit is gradient descent
which is ubiquitous in machine learning
so what that means is that you have your
hypothesis describe your AI is described
by a whole bunch of numbers a whole
bunch of knobs that each one of the
knobs has a small effect on its behavior
and you go and you have an example and
you look at the example and you see well
did it get it right and if it didn't
would it have gotten closer to getting
it right if you tweak the knobs a little
bit and if you do you tweak them a
little bit in that direction right and
then you keep going see another example
and tweak the knobs again and if you see
a million such examples then all of
those little tweaks add up to a fairly
well tuned artificial intelligence right
hypothesis okay but there's a lot more
right I mean there's linear algebra
right there's functional analysis
there's I mean I wind up having to learn
a lot of tools in order to be able to
put them together to design a new
algorithm how is a researcher do you
sort through mm-hm and say I want to
follow that path for a while right I
mean there's a lot of trial and error
you learn to recognize what promising
paths are and then there's a lot of
collaboration like one of the key things
for research is that you can't do it in
a vacuum you really need to get a good
team of people together to make progress
and I don't just mean a good team of
people at one lab although you know
obviously that's really important
there's like a whole research community
right and they all build on each other's
work and so it's really important to
have that community I think we called
that open source research yes so so open
source code but I mean there's that
necessary collaboration right I mean you
can't do it on your own the problems are
just too hard and so you have to you
know one person will have an idea to
advance the state-of-the-art just a
little bit in some direction and then
somebody else will say oh well now that
I know that this thing I was trying to
do becomes easier and now I know how to
do this other thing and if you have a
thousand people each learning about the
other people's contributions you make
more than a thousand times as much
progress so let's circle back to
Montreal for a second young big plans
for the lab there what are you looking
for who are you looking for where are
you looking for them hmm I mean we are
looking for people who are creative
about how they decide to attack problems
we're looking for people with great
skills you know I mentioned that there
are all of these mathematical tools that
you need to put together to design the
algorithms if you don't know the tools
then you can't be creative about how to
use them and you know there's this
desire for exploration right that's like
the key thing in a researcher you have
to be driven by wanting to know what
makes the world tick because otherwise
you would just never be able to devote
so much time and energy into solving a
problem for people like you researchers
with PhDs who
that joy of discovery and the requisite
skill set there have been traditionally
two places you could go either academia
or industry how is Microsoft Research
similar or different
Microsoft has decided that Microsoft
Research will attack the big questions
with the sort of which implies right
that you cannot know ahead of time
exactly what's going to come out because
if you knew it wouldn't be research and
it implies that you don't expect your
payoffs to be measured in months or even
you know necessarily a couple of years
but it could be that the things you're
doing now pay off ten years later and so
Microsoft has decided that MSR is in it
for the long term and that changes the
type of research that you can do right
you can afford to make big bets when you
don't have to deliver the result of your
work into a product in two months so
very much pure research as opposed to
Applied Research yes however you're
seeing more and more of the work coming
out of MSR that's right so you wind up
doing this work and then once you've you
know you don't necessarily know what
you're gonna get when you start but once
you do it you look and you see that it's
going to wind up being incredibly useful
for some software or hardware product
that Microsoft is making or is
considering making right so I've seen
researchers who asked a question that I
would have said was completely abstract
right no immediate connection to a
product and then a couple of years later
it turns out being sold to businesses
around the world as a new piece of
software so that to me suggests that
there is a lifting of the burden of
success immediately right that allows
you to ask a bunch of different kinds of
questions that's right that's right the
freedom from having to know that you
will get results in the short term right
allows you to ask harder questions where
you'll get results but maybe not the
ones you were looking for in the longer
term because you never achieve what you
set out to achieve exactly right you
achieve something good but never exactly
what you thought you would
and so makes it tough to plan but you
know it makes it fun
right because you're always seeing
something new something you didn't
expect yeah
difficult to plan and also difficult to
measure mm-hm if you have like a
performance review it's like well I
really did accomplish quite a bit yeah I
mean there's you know people have
developed a whole bunch of imperfect
metrics so there's the metric of just
counting how many papers you publish
right but researchers as they make
progress will write down pieces of that
progress and you can look at them and
you can see oh you know that was clever
to be able to make that chunk of
progress even if I don't know what it's
gonna be good for right yet but I'll bet
that something good will come out of
that and that's the sort of thing that
you try to learn through experience and
training how to recognize what types of
research outputs are likely to lead to
sort of further progress down the road
right and again it's hard but that's
sort of your short term measure of
progress you can look at you know what
did you figure out today I love that
though yeah I mean how rewarding is that
oh it's very rewarding
for people who really wanted to you know
take apart the world and see what makes
it tick it's really cool to discover
something new that you didn't know about
how the world works to add to the sum of
human knowledge
[Music]
Jeff we're experiencing a kind of AI
goldrush you and I talked about the fact
that companies of all stripes trying to
snap up the best talent yes and their
forest that they're clear-cutting is
often universities yes what if we clerk
cut all the talent and training the next
generation is yoshua bengio said takes a
long time to train a PhD it does I've
experienced that so who I think that we
have to try and set it up so that it's
not just a stark decision between
pulling people into industry and
training the next generation one of the
things that's great about MSR Montreal
is we have an explicit goal of working
with the local universities of
contributing to training so a lot of our
faculty in universities are interested
in collaborating with the researchers at
Microsoft Research and a lot of the
researchers at Microsoft Research are
interested in for example seeking out
adjunct positions at local universities
being able to work with the students
there and sometimes teach classes
sometimes teach in the sense of
apprenticeship so that it doesn't have
to be either/or right you can be part of
a great lab like MSR and still
contribute to training the next
generation and there are different
motivators for different people right
well it's the same thing that I said
before in order to be good at research
you have to enjoy the thrill of
discovery right you have to really want
to know how the world works and I think
if you set up a research lab well it
makes a big difference for how fun it is
to work there how interesting how
rewarding it is to work there
I think MSR has really done a great job
of setting that balance I ask this of
all the researchers I interview usually
after a long conversation that
essentially covers what gets them up in
the morning mm-hmm
so given the work you do
even though we don't know all the future
implications let's say we do succeed
succeed in teaching machines to interact
with humans the way humans interact with
humans is there anything about that
scenario that keeps you up at night
I think if you're gonna worry about
something with AI you should worry about
people misusing AI right so that could
be intentional misuse where you design
an AI to accomplish some evil task right
as you said here industro cuter fluffy
white cat right but more likely it's
going to be accidental there's all sorts
of things where if you don't spend a
little bit of thought about how your AI
is gonna learn then you can treat people
very poorly very unfairly and so there's
this whole area of AI research called
fate fairness accountability
transparency and ethics and that's
actually one of the areas that MSR is
strong in very strong and so we're
looking at for example how do you train
AI algorithms so that they are not
biased when they make their decisions
the problem is you train these things on
past decisions and so you learn to copy
them right you told the algorithm copy
these human decision data set right and
so if the data set is biased then the
algorithms are gonna learn to copy that
bias very efficiently and extend it to
more people and so you have to be
careful right if you do things naively
without thinking you will freeze
whatever bias was in the training set
and then ship it out to a much larger
number of people right and so there's
been a lot of examples where people have
accidentally done that but there are
also lots of researchers working on how
do you despite bias training data train
your AI to be fair and be unbiased as we
finish here Jeff what advice would you
give to researchers that are in that
space now or they're going to make a
career decision what do I do with my
life where do I go I've got a lot of
options now that I didn't have right I
mean when you have lots of options you
should always think about what you can
accomplish with them do you just want to
go
with the gold rush stick your pen in the
water and hopefully find a few nuggets
or do you want to solve the world's
problems or do you want to learn what
makes the world work and when you have
the options you have the luxury of being
able to make choices that actually
achieve the goals that you have for
yourself and so my advice is to think
carefully about what you want think
about whether you want to learn how the
world works or whether you just want to
make some money right now there's a big
difference in how you create your
options in these two cases yeah well
Jeff Gordon you are so fascinating to me
thanks for coming in thank you to learn
more about dr. Jeff Gordon and the
latest innovations in machine learning
visit microsoft.com slash research